a given rapid mix unit receives 2 MGD of
flow at 70° fhe and has a design
retention time of 2 minutes the power
imparted to the impeller is 1866 fet
pound per second what is the resulting
head loss in feet so the first thing we
want to do in this problem is search for
Rapid mix searching for this in the
reference manual will take us to chapter
6 section
6.9.1 point2 to a section called
mixing there is an equation there for
Rapid mix and flul design that we can
write out now so the equation is G
equal p over mu * V all to the square
root equals gamma * head loss over T *
mu also to the square root where G is
the velocity gradient p is the power V
is volume mu is dynamic
viscosity gamma is specific weight of
water HL is the head loss and T is
time so the problem is asking us to find
the head loss in terms of feet and the
problem also gives us some of the other
information that we're going to need to
solve this problem so let's write this
out and begin to
simplify
so step one we can see that we aren't
given any information about velocity
gradient in the problem or term G here
so we can remove that and then simplify
this equation even
more after we remove G we can remove mu
from both side of the
equation and we can also remove the
square root so the equation will
simplify down to P over V equals gamma
time head
loss over
time plugging in our
know we can write as follows power equal
1866 foot
pound over
second volume we don't know yet but we
can solve
for and on this other side of the
equation gamma we can also find
which we'll do in a moment head loss is
what we're solving for and T is time
given in seconds we're given it up here
in minutes so 2 minutes * 60 seconds is
going to be 120
seconds and that's
it all we need to do now is find the
volume and find gamma and we can solve
this
out so the volume is given here
as the
flow so we can calculate that as
follows volume
equals 2 mg D times our conversion of 1
CFS to
MGD and from here we can multiply it by
the retention time to find the amount of
volume that stays in the rapid mix
unit
so 2 minutes
times 60 seconds per
minute and this will give us an answer
of about
37128 ft
cubed we can see here that MGD and MGD
cancels out minutes and minutes cancel
out and of the cubic feet per second
here seconds and seconds will cancel out
leaving us with cubic
feet so we can write this at the bottom
here
371 28 cubic
feet and finally we need to find
gamma so if you're completely stumped
you could probably guess that gamma
equals
62.4 pounds per cubic foot as that's the
standard unit weight of water but there
is somewhere else we can get it so in
this case gamma comes from section
6.2.1 six on page
316 of version 1.2 of the reference
manual in a table
called properties of
water
on this table various physical
properties of water are
recorded at different
temperatures so at 70° fah we can see on
the table that gamma equals
62.3 pound per cubic
feet I should note that this table also
provides the viscosity if you had ended
up needing that for this problem as well
so plugging that into the equation all
we have to do after this is solve for
the P
loss so if we multiply the time over and
then divide out the gamma to isolate
HL we can see that this equals just
about
968 ft and our closest answer over here
is
9.7 so this problem can actually be
solved very quickly if you understand
just a few things first you'll have to
know that given that this is a rapid mix
problem there is an equation for Rapid
mix in this following
section further recognizing how to
simplify it down so that you don't need
to find two terms in this table and
indeed you might not even need to use
gamma from this table since 62.3 is very
close to 62. for if you had had that in
your head granted it's always good to
check if you have the time because at a
drastically different temperature you
might find that the value is different
enough to skew your
answer and finally you just have to know
that your flow rate here can be
converted into a volume of the rapid mix
unit by knowing how much flow is passing
through and how long that flow is
detained for in the
unit
knowing these things you'll be able to
solve this equation very quickly and get
your head loss it's also worth noting
that this section contains a number of
other equations that the test could ask
you about so it's probably a good idea
to get familiar with both this section
as well as the physical properties of
water table in this
section if you do that in advance you'll
be able to more efficiently tackle
problems like this on the exam day and
that's it